[Music]
you ever see something online and you
make that exact expression well then
this video for you prepared to get your
best hmm face on cuz you're we're about
to go on mmm-hmm journey where we gonna
met things it's this joke getting old
yes it is already great that is very
interesting but men are having fun in
there in the living room while the women
is doing the dishes
[Music]
it's interesting how back in the days we
were so wrong
look how wrong we were very interesting
well I guess houses need electricity too
interesting
it all makes sense that is not hmm that
is disgusting
that's disgusting take it away from me
please mmm what pancake the classic one
in a row game that's not that that's a
Photoshop that's not real I'm not gonna
whom it that one that's a faker
that's not worthy at all uh-huh last
night that's not huh hmm that's whom
this is real why does it look so weird
the mirror is curved
oh why of course look everyone its
youtuber high school look I'll leave
normally good one why just why why can I
ask that at least hmm now I see it hmm
what is happening here
that man is invisible but if he's
invisible then why is he wearing
clothing oh the socks it's the socks
okay I get it
it was the socks all along hilarious
[Music]
absolute mad lad why would anyone do
that I wonder what a chair tastes like
hmm who would ever know have you ever
tried a chair oh so long cuz he's a
puppet right I literally watched Muppets
as a kid they scare me
now that's hmm
was Lincoln an alien all along maybe
perhaps I think yes yes confirmed mmm
maddis that's a radiator hmm I don't
believe that is actually a functioning
light I believe that's indeed a
basketball a basketball inside the line
very interesting well done well played
[Music]
that is not a laptop that is a toast
making machine or is it hmm we've all
had this mistake at least once rushed
out the door and grabbed the panini
press instead of the laptop happens to
the best of us it truly does but at
least you get to do some delicious toast
while you're at school it's a huge feed
into a USB charger I've infiltrated the
system I wonder actually what would
happen what would happen you have those
self-destructing USBs right but where
does it end
did the pencil become a teacher or did
the teacher become a pencil there is no
teacher I need to do this next time I
mean in Italy
[Music]
that's this a funny idea I don't know
that's not that doesn't make me mmm okay
that does not make me um I wanna be whom
is that a Photoshop no way that slice of
banana looks just like the dog it's the
dog that banana reincarnated soul
perhaps what am I looking at Elmo please
stop this is not food this is do you
ever hate when you take off your sweater
and you realize your legs go all the way
up into your your chin wait I can just
click there I had no idea seriously I
didn't never knew how to use reddit
before Jesus that man is turning to her
wood oh my god that's disgusting
but also what the hell is with this
picture
stop this is a cursed image this is not
making me room that's made me earth dogs
can't take selfies everyone knows that
stop looking at me yes
maybe he did run off to South Africa and
took some age reducing drugs and came
back to the New York subway hmm it is
possible if you think about it not too
hard
why I love the girls reaction what is
that why what's the point
hmm truly making you think err on the
pide pide channel it's really making you
elevate your mind do you feel like
you're being exorcised not a lot of
people would understand pictures like
this but not that
oh my god there's a cat inside the cat
hmm I'm getting really tired of
hiccupping I mean that just make sense I
would do the same thing but then again
why would you need the chair in the
first place
oh I've seen this one Wow some delicious
mochi sirs hmm still delicious of course
all right here we have ed sheeran I
thought it was leaves I've always had my
suspected suspicions that Ed Sheeran had
an army of leaves with his own face on
it but now it's confirm that is so sweet
she's finally going to get a nose hmm
isn't it wonderful when people hmm get a
nose this is a great photo show I don't
know what else to say about that one
what am I looking at what is this I mean
can statues actually say no to
cigarettes how interesting
[Music]
how did that happen maybe you get
smarter once you get your passport
that's where it is where do you work at
it delayed really I wonder with his
later years cuz the face is blurred hmm
I need to get this I need to get this
haircut please how can I do it that is
it possible
probably not but hmm wow that's an
interesting face makeup okay I think I
think that was enough moving today let
me know in the comments what makes you
or perhaps move maybe you're more of a
[Music]